[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis on se croit pas
trop
mais oui mon gros nounours descend vite
leur montrer ton beau livre et moi je
raconte la suite des aventures de notre
petite amie cornichons ou le jeune
[Musique]
cornichons vous vous en rappelez les
enfants s'est perdu et il est à la
recherche depuis plusieurs jours de ses
parents et de son cheval dada vous êtes
prêt nounours je peux raconter
nous sommes heureux en vous intro image
à notre petits cornichons marche très
longtemps dans la grande forêt il y a
beaucoup d'arbres mais aussi beaucoup de
ronces des fougères et des chardons qui
lui piquent les jambes
moi j'aime mieux les fougères ou au
dessus ce plutôt jeunes et notre petite
amie qui est fatigué ça soit sur un
tapis de mousse et s'endort et il ne
voit pas l'écureuil qui saute de branche
en branche
le petit hérisson curieux qui vient le
regarder la biche et le cerf ils ne
voient pas l'escargot la limace ils ne
voient pas la souris grise ni le bébé
marcassins ni le lièvre il ne voit pas
le renard au museau pointu ni les
oiseaux ils ne voient pas tous les
animaux qui se sont approchés de lui il
ne voit rien bien sûr
dans aussi de match les enfants écoutent
la chute le bûcheron qui coupent des
arbres dans la forêt fait comme ses amis
animaux et vient à voir notre petit
dormeur
mais il a froid ce petit tout seul sur
la mousse
alors il prend doucement cornichons dans
ses bras et l'emportent dans sa cabane
il le pose auprès d'un bon flux de bois
et lorsque notre petit garçon se
réveille il se trouve en face d'une très
grosse barbe en haleine bape ce but il
doit pas avoir froid
nicolas qui n'ont ni comment ni pourquoi
t'as pas une barre comme ça toi gosse
j'ai cédé elle ne veut pas pousser
réchauffe toi petit lui dit la grosse
voix du bûcheron à travers sa grosse
barbe et mangeons la soupe et notre
petits cornichons partage avec son
nouvel ami un délicieux potage aux
plantes de la forêt avec de la crème
fraîche
quel veinard ses cornichons cornichons
c'est bien réchauffé et il part en
compagnie du bûcheron travailler dans la
grande forêt il est quoi j'étais petit
comique c'est pas comme toi nicolas
allons les enfants l'histoire est finie
[Musique]
ce qu'ils sont non
on est aussi venus et qu'on à 9
bonne nuit les petits la jettent un lay
up
un tome bonne nuit petit nicolas bonne
nuit petit 1 prenait lé 28 tous les
enfants allez vite vous coucher
auparavant n'oubliez pas de faire votre
toilette et de bien vous l'a vu le don
qui faites de beaux rêves
à demain bolden
[Musique]